so whatever we think if we think of J
Edgar Hoover Jagger Hoover will appear
in destroy us first time I ever heard of
jr. Hoover ghostbusters J Edgar so J
Edgar's directed by Clint Eastwood it
stars Leonardo DiCaprio who plays J
Edgar Hoover who's the guy who founded
the FBI I almost said the CIA no FBI now
I was really looking forward to this
movie it's Clint Eastwood directing it's
Oscar season so alright this is one I
might be able to sink my teeth into and
how was it hmm to be fair the movies a
biopic it's about Jagger Hoover's life I
mean there's one scene where he's like a
little kid but it starts out when he's
probably in his 20s maybe he's very
determined he's very focused on his job
he's like I want to make the nation to
stay for place you know those commies
are out there and we can't have that
[ __ ] the movie is well acted but this
movie is really long it's probably 2
hours 15 minutes long 2 hours 10 without
credits but at a point you know about a
half an hour before the movie was done I
was like this movie really needs to wrap
it up dude when you start wishing for a
movie to wrap it up you know something
fell along the lines and it bounces back
and forth between when he's young when
he's old when he's young when he's old
it's funny Leonardo DiCaprio an old guy
makeup looks a lot like Jon Voight I
thought and the Winklevoss guy he plays
Jagger Hoover's number 2 man so he has
this gay relationship with also that no
one can know about you know because [ __ ]
it's the 16 she can't do that
not when you're J Edgar Hoover no one
can know that you're involved with the
wincle vibe and you dress in your mom's
dress so when the movie bounces back and
forth between Winnie's young and when
he's old some of the transitions work I
liked how they were like they'll be old
and an elevator and then we'll get out
of the elevator and they're young all
right that's cool sometimes it just
changes on a snap you're like wait you
don't have the lost thing you know on
the show lost when it's gonna go to a
flashback you know that ambient noise
you know it kind of triggers your brain
going okay here we go flashback time
this movie doesn't have that so takes
your brain you know a couple seconds to
register but that is two seconds you
could have spent concentrating on the
movie and all the make up you know old
dude makeup it's almost like this
movie's a biopic that's not based off of
a Jagger Hoover biopic book it's like
it's based on a jig or Hoover section of
a history book you know like the college
history books are like that thick yeah
that it's like here are the facts ladies
and gentlemen just laying it out there
for you and after about two hours ten
minutes of that the movie ends you're
like okay well that was the movie that
was Jagger Hoover's life but it is
interesting to see how the FBI came to
be all the forensic investigations that
we take for granted now the stuffs
everywhere back then it was like
evolutionary and people thought it was
just weird oh that's just wishful stats
not science you're like oh yeah you're a
revolutionary guy you've created a lot
of cool stuff that's awesome that being
said you're a dick sometimes the coolest
parts of the movie is when they would
reference things that I would know like
babyface Nelson John Dillinger I saw
Public Enemies yeah that's when I was
like oh okay yeah Christian Bale and
Depp and all that good stuff I'm gonna
level with you guys people might love
this movie but I thought it was really
long really boring really well acted but
kind of poorly edited in the end I'll
say this movie is okay but you're not
gonna remember in t-minus two hours if
you saw J Edgar Hoover special unlike
the History Channel it would probably be
more interesting so your favorite Clint
Eastwood movie what is it whatever it is
a guy's directed a [ __ ] ton of movies
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]